Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. The topic for this episode is the mind-gut connection. Is your gut a second brain? Emerging research is showing that our brains and our gastrointestinal systems may be more connected than we previously thought, potentially holding profound influence over our moods, mental health, and sense of well-being. This exciting new frontier of scientific knowledge has captured a lot of people's attention, yet there's still so much we don't know. Our guests for this episode are Dr. Faith Dickerson, a psychologist who is the head of the Stanley Research Team at Shepard Pret Health System, where she researches the role of infectious
欢迎收听美国心理学会的双周播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本期节目的主题是“身心肠道联系”。你的肠道是第二个大脑吗？新兴研究表明，我们的大脑和胃肠系统之间的联系可能比我们之前认为的更为紧密，并可能对我们的情绪、心理健康和幸福感产生深远影响。这一令人兴奋的科学知识新领域吸引了许多人的关注，但我们仍有许多未知之处。本期节目的嘉宾是费思·迪克森博士，她是一位心理学家，也是谢泼德·普拉特健康系统斯坦利研究团队的负责人，她在那里研究传染因素和免疫因素在严重精神疾病中的作用；以及埃默兰·迈耶博士，他是一位专门研究胃肠病学的医学博士，也是全球脑肠互动与胃肠疾病领域领先的专家之一。他们二人都曾登上《心理学监测》2018年12月刊的封面故事，该杂志是美国心理学会为会员提供的刊物，涵盖科学、教育、心理学实践等内容。欢迎迪克森博士和迈耶博士。你好。很高兴来到这个节目。
and immune factors in serious mental illness, and Dr. Emeran Mayer, a medical doctor who specializes in gastroenterology. He's one of the world's leading experts on brain gut interactions in GI disorders. Both were featured in the cover story on this topic in the December 2018 issue of the Monitor on Psychology, APA's magazine for members that covers science, education, psychology practice, and more. Welcome, Dr. Dickerson and Dr. Mayor. Hello. Nice to be in the show.
（接上文）以及免疫因素在严重精神疾病中的作用；以及埃默兰·迈耶博士，他是一位专门研究胃肠病学的医学博士，也是全球脑肠互动与胃肠疾病领域领先的专家之一。他们二人都曾登上《心理学监测》2018年12月刊的封面故事，该杂志是美国心理学会为会员提供的刊物，涵盖科学、教育、心理学实践等内容。欢迎迪克森博士和迈耶博士。你好。很高兴来到这个节目。
Let's start off with a basic question, Dr. Mayor. What is a gut microbiome and what does it do? So the term microbiome is being used to refer both to the population and relative abundances of microbes. live in our gut, as well as its function, basically related to the genetic material and the ability to generate metabolites and substances that can influence various functions throughout the body. So the microbiome is both the relative abundance of organisms as well as the function of the system. microbiota in contrast is used only to refer to the relative abundances. So what does that do for us in our intestines?
让我们从一个基本问题开始，迈耶博士。什么是肠道微生物组，它有什么作用？“微生物组”这个术语既指微生物的种群及其相对丰度，这些微生物生活在我们的肠道中，也指其功能，基本上与遗传物质以及产生代谢物和能够影响全身各种功能的物质的能力有关。因此，微生物组既是生物体的相对丰度，也是系统的功能。相比之下，“微生物群”仅用于指代相对丰度。那么，它在我们的肠道中为我们做了什么呢？
Well, it does a lot. And we're currently in a phase that people think it's involved in just about every normal, healthy function and in a large growing number of diseases. It basically, the most basic function, that's why that symbiosis developed a long time ago, millions of years ago, is that the microbes have the ability to break down opponents of food, mainly plant-based foods, fibers that we don't, that we humans don't have the enzymes to break them down. This was even more important with our ancestors who were not able to cook things and break down some of the fibers. And they produce substances, the most well-known ones being the short-chain fatty acids like butyrate. They then act with these substances or metabolites, they can talk to each other. They can talk to our gut.
嗯，它做了很多事情。我们目前处于一个阶段，人们认为它几乎参与了所有正常的健康功能，并与越来越多的疾病有关。它最基本的功能——这也是为什么这种共生关系在很久以前，几百万年前就发展起来的原因——是微生物有能力分解食物成分，主要是植物性食物和纤维，而我们人类没有分解它们的酶。这对于我们的祖先来说更为重要，因为他们无法烹饪食物来分解某些纤维。它们产生物质，最著名的是丁酸盐等短链脂肪酸。然后它们利用这些物质或代谢物进行交流。它们可以相互交流，也可以与我们的肠道交流。
and they also can talk to distant organs from the heart, the liver and the brain. So they have a lot of other functions. I mean, they, for example, can metabolize many medications. They can metabolize sex hormones like estrogen and proteoprogynous and testosterone and testosterone. They can deal with substances. So there's many substances that we now, understand are kind of targeted at microbiome, large molecules. So, for example, so-called polyphenols, so the health benefit producing substances that are in many plants, including blueberries
它们还可以与心脏、肝脏和大脑等远端器官进行交流。所以它们还有许多其他功能。例如，它们可以代谢许多药物。它们可以代谢雌激素、孕激素和睾酮等性激素。它们可以处理各种物质。因此，我们现在了解到许多物质实际上是以微生物组为目标的，比如大分子。例如，所谓的“多酚”，即许多植物（包括蓝莓和橄榄）中含有的产生健康益处的物质。
and olives. Infants can break down large molecules called human milk oligosaccharides that cannot be absorbed by the baby from breast milk, but they go directly down to the microbes, metabolize them. So there's many, many substances that we are learning, that we are learning now that would, would, would, would this plays a role. This, you know, this, formally, it's kind of interesting to me always that, that, that people could write medical textbooks without taking this into consideration. that any of our medicines or therapies really work without having taken this system into consideration.
婴儿可以分解被称为“人乳寡糖”的大分子，这些分子无法被婴儿从母乳中吸收，但它们直接进入肠道，由微生物进行代谢。所以我们现在正在学习许多许多物质，它们在其中发挥了作用。对我来说，人们在编写医学教科书时竟然不考虑这一点，或者在不考虑这个系统的情况下，我们的任何药物或疗法是否真的有效，这总是让我觉得很有趣。
And there's a lot we don't know yet, correct, about what the gut microbiome does and what it can do. This is what people forget. We're at the very beginning of this. You know, we have extremely powerful ways to analyze them. So that's actually made this whole field possible. all sequencing techniques, you know, which used to be extremely expensive, $100,000 per stool sample. Now I can do it for $20. But I think people tend to forget this is a very complex ecosystem with regional differences from the stomach all the way down to the colon.
关于肠道微生物组的作用及其潜力，我们还有很多未知之处，对吗？这就是人们容易忘记的地方。我们正处于这一领域的起步阶段。你知道，我们拥有极其强大的分析手段，这实际上使整个领域成为可能。所有的测序技术，你知道，过去极其昂贵，每个粪便样本需要10万美元。现在我可以用20美元完成。但我认为人们往往会忘记，这是一个非常复杂的生态系统，从胃一直到结肠，区域差异很大。
It's not the same. and we pick up and we measure relative abundances and metabolites in the stool, I mean, that's a mixture of all of those regions. It's kind of, if you look at the world, like extrapolate this to the world, it would be like homogenizing information or mixing blood samples from every country on earth and trying to make sense from these mixed results, what people do in these individual countries or what diseases they have.
它不是一成不变的。我们采集并测量粪便中的相对丰度和代谢物，那实际上是所有这些区域的混合物。如果你把这推演到全世界，就像是把全球的信息同质化，或者把地球上每个国家的血液样本混合在一起，然后试图从这些混合的结果中弄清楚人们在这些国家里做了什么，或者他们患有什么疾病。
So I think that's kind of where we are right now. I would say optimistically even, I think we understand about 10% at best what that system can do, what is capable to do, and what role it may play in various diseases. And I want to turn over to Dr. Dickerson because you mentioned in that Monitor article the idea of bacteria in your gut influencing your behavior
所以我认为这就是我们目前的处境。我甚至可以乐观地说，我认为我们充其量只了解了这个系统能做什么、它有能力做什么，以及它在各种疾病中可能扮演的角色的大约10%。我想请教迪克森博士，因为您在《监测》那篇文章中提到了肠道细菌影响行为的观点。
of mental health would have seemed kooky only 10 years ago. And now there's a lot of public interest in this topic. So what do you think has changed? Right. I think a number of things have changed. At least three reasons can account for this interest. One that Dr. Mayor mentioned was that the techniques that we now have to measure the microbiome have really become much more sophisticated and much more.
心理健康在10年前看起来似乎很古怪。而现在，公众对这个话题非常感兴趣。那么您认为发生了什么变化？是的，我认为发生了许多变化。至少有三个原因可以解释这种兴趣。迈耶博士提到的第一个原因是，我们现在测量微生物组的技术已经变得更加复杂和实用。
more practical. The methods that are used, people may not realize, are the same methods that are used to measure the human genome. And we know that these techniques have rapidly progressed over the last couple of decades. So that we now measure the microbiome and the organisms that make up the microbiome with these same methods. And the technical complexity is truly impressive and has enabled this research to take place. I think the second reason that the idea seems less kooky for all of us have to do with the very elegant animal experiments that have been done. And it's important to emphasize that most of what we understand about the microbiome has been carried out in animal studies, particularly with mice. And we can get into some discussion
更加实用。人们可能没有意识到，所使用的方法与测量人类基因组的方法相同。我们知道，这些技术在过去几十年里取得了飞速发展。因此，我们现在用同样的方法来测量微生物组和构成微生物组的生物体。这种技术复杂性确实令人印象深刻，并使这项研究得以开展。我认为第二个原因，即这个想法对我们所有人来说看起来不那么古怪，与所做的非常优雅的动物实验有关。必须强调的是，我们对微生物组的大部分了解都是通过动物研究，特别是小鼠研究得出的。我们可以讨论一下
about how we translate those findings from animals to humans, but to suffice it to say that there are many advantages, obviously, in working with animals, one of which is that one can work with germ-free animals, which do not have these microbes. You can't, you know, really work with germ-free people, but you can work with germ-free mice, and that enables one to introduce these organisms and to study the effects of the organisms in a very systematic way. And obviously, animals can be sacrificed and one can study the contents of their GI tract and the effect of the microbiome on the brain in ways that would be absolutely impossible in humans. Right, right. But I think that the third reason is in some ways a little more distant but also
关于我们如何将这些发现从动物转化为人类，但足以说明的是，在动物身上工作显然有很多优势，其中之一就是可以使用无菌动物，它们体内没有这些微生物。你不能真正地在无菌人身上工作，但你可以在无菌小鼠身上工作，这使人们能够引入这些生物体并以非常系统的方式研究它们的影响。显然，动物可以被处死，人们可以研究它们的胃肠道内容物以及微生物组对大脑的影响，这在人类身上是绝对不可能实现的。没错，没错。但我认为第三个原因在某些方面稍微遥远一些，但也
relevant to this discussion. I think the idea of the immune system and the gut brain access having a role in human behavior and in psychological and psychiatric problems also has to be seen in the context of the larger world of science and particularly of our understanding of genetics. Because it was really felt a number of years ago by many of us that human genetics would really turn out to be more easily explanatory for the psychological and psychiatric problems that people face. And I think that that area of research has been somewhat disappointing. And we don't really have clear answers yet from human genetics about the etiology of complex psychiatric disorders.
与这次讨论相关。我认为免疫系统和脑肠轴在人类行为以及心理和精神问题中发挥作用的观点，也必须在更广阔的科学背景下，特别是我们对遗传学的理解背景下看待。因为几年前我们许多人确实认为，人类遗传学最终会更容易解释人们面临的心理和精神问题。我认为该领域的研究在某种程度上令人失望。我们目前还没有从人类遗传学中得到关于复杂精神疾病病因的明确答案。
And the genetic studies, to my understanding, have not really led yet to effective treatments. So I think with the course of that research, it has enabled scientists and the general public to be more open to other paradigms. So I think that's an important aspect of how this idea seems a little less kooky because we're now open to other realms in terms of our understanding. And as we've said a few times, this is all in the early stages, but I wanted to talk about some of the intriguing findings that have emerged. People with GI disorders have higher than average rates of bipolar disorders and depression. People with schizophrenia often have blood markers that suggest GI inflammation, and people on the autism spectrum have higher
据我所知，基因研究尚未真正带来有效的治疗方法。因此，我认为随着研究的进展，它使科学家和公众能够对其他范式持更加开放的态度。所以我认为这是这个想法看起来不那么古怪的一个重要方面，因为我们现在对理解的其他领域持开放态度。正如我们已经提到的几次，这一切都处于早期阶段，但我还是想谈谈一些已经出现的有趣发现。患有胃肠道疾病的人患双相情感障碍和抑郁症的比例高于平均水平。精神分裂症患者通常有提示胃肠道炎症的血液标志物，而自闭症谱系障碍患者的胃肠道问题比例也高于平均水平。
rates of GI problems than average population. So although we know this is in the early stages, what are those findings tell us? Well, I mean, I would make some comments and then turn it over to Dr. Mayor, I mean, I think these associations, they're very consistent and they're very intriguing, and I think they highlight that there is an association among the brain, the immune system, and the gut. But they don't tell us really what's the direction of that association and what is the causality. And again, we're studying these phenomena in animal models, and we can talk to the extent that animal models of psychopathology, have relevance to human disease, but I think they provide a very solid foundation for this area of research. Yeah, I would comment on this with, you know, I've always been a skeptic.
高于平均水平。所以，尽管我们知道这还处于早期阶段，但这些发现告诉了我们什么？嗯，我会发表一些评论，然后请迈耶博士谈谈。我认为这些关联非常一致且非常有趣，我认为它们强调了大脑、免疫系统和肠道之间存在关联。但它们并没有真正告诉我们这种关联的方向是什么，以及因果关系是什么。同样，我们正在动物模型中研究这些现象，我们可以讨论动物精神病理学模型与人类疾病的相关性，但我认为它们为该领域的研究提供了非常坚实的基础。是的，我会对此发表评论，你知道，我一直是个怀疑论者。
I mean, that's why I'm a scientist. And so, you know, I believe something one once really had a definitive proof for it. And I totally agree with the problem that we have. It's really twofold. One is that the most exciting studies and results about the communication between the microbiome and the brain have come from mouse studies, mouse behavior. Obviously, the mice can't talk. The mice don't have this highly complex brain that we have, particularly the prefrontal cortex.
我的意思是，这就是为什么我是一名科学家。所以，你知道，我只有在真正有了确凿证据时才会相信某件事。我完全同意我们面临的问题。这实际上是双重的。一是关于微生物组与大脑之间交流的最令人兴奋的研究和结果来自小鼠研究，小鼠行为。显然，小鼠不会说话。小鼠没有我们拥有的这种高度复杂的大脑，特别是前额叶皮层。
So it's like comparing a HP hand, hand, calculator with the Watson IBM supercomputer. And the second thing is the mice. So there's hundreds of different mouse strains. There's actually a panel with all these different mouse strains. You can do an experiment in one of these strains with the microbiota and brain and you won't see an effect and then you do it in a different strain and you see the effect. So we don't know which one of these.
所以这就像把惠普手持计算器与IBM沃森超级计算机进行比较。第二件事是小鼠。有数百种不同的小鼠品系。实际上有一个包含所有这些不同小鼠品系的面板。你可以在其中一个品系中用微生物群和大脑进行实验，你可能看不到效果，然后在另一个品系中做，你就会看到效果。所以我们不知道是哪一个。
So scientists pick the ones where they see the effect. We don't really know if that relates to humans. And I think we have to differentiate. So the brain gut interaction and particularly the interaction of the brain with the gut associated immune system is the biggest part of our immune system that sits in the gut. That's kind of a well-established entity and field of science. We know stress changes the immune function. We know that immune activation in the gut can lead to withdrawal behavior that's often been taken as a depression-like behavior.
所以科学家们选择了他们能看到效果的那些。我们真的不知道这是否与人类有关。我认为我们必须区分。所以脑肠互动，特别是大脑与肠道相关免疫系统的互动——这是我们免疫系统中最大的一部分，位于肠道中——这是一种相当成熟的实体和科学领域。我们知道压力会改变免疫功能。我们知道肠道中的免疫激活会导致退缩行为，这通常被视为抑郁样行为。
And many studies have looked at this. And actually, I would say there's some studies that prove causality from the brain to the gut and to the immune system. and vice versa. The problem with the microbiome, we don't have that yet in humans. So it could easily be, and I'm going to tell you a study that I think in some way supports that it could easily be that all these changes we see in gut microbial composition and function and metabolite production in patient populations with different brain or psychiatric disorders are a consequence of the output of the brain, of the disease to the gut,
许多研究都关注了这一点。实际上，我想说有一些研究证明了从大脑到肠道再到免疫系统的因果关系，反之亦然。微生物组的问题在于，我们在人类身上还没有做到这一点。所以这很容易——我要告诉你一个我认为在某种程度上支持这一点的研究——很有可能我们在患有不同大脑或精神疾病的患者群体中看到的肠道微生物组成、功能和代谢物产生的所有这些变化，都是大脑疾病对肠道输出的结果，
which we know changes a lot of functions, has effects on the environment that these microbes live in, but also directly on the microbes. Or if there's really primary changes in the microbiome that either started in infancy or are related to intake of medications, many of which modulate the microbiome and then generate signals that they contribute to the, to cause the brain disease. So this, and just give you one example, there's many studies now in mice, monkeys, humans,
我们知道这会改变许多功能，对这些微生物生存的环境产生影响，也会直接影响微生物。或者，如果微生物组确实存在最初的变化，这些变化要么始于婴儿期，要么与药物摄入有关（其中许多药物会调节微生物组），然后产生信号，导致大脑疾病。所以，仅举一个例子，现在有许多关于小鼠、猴子和人类的研究，
that psychological stress can change the relative abundance, for example, a decrease in lactobacillin, a change in triptophen metabolism that's related. to this lactobacillin. And we recently completed a study with Jeff Flackner at University of Buffalo that showed that the patients who underwent, these were patients with IBS that underwent cognitive behavioral therapy. We looked at the responders versus the non-responders. And the responders showed not only changes in the brain, but also in the relative
心理压力可以改变相对丰度，例如，乳酸杆菌减少，与这种乳酸杆菌相关的色氨酸代谢发生变化。我们最近与布法罗大学的杰夫·弗莱克纳完成了一项研究，结果显示，接受认知行为疗法的肠易激综合征（IBS）患者，我们观察了有反应者与无反应者。有反应者不仅在大脑中表现出变化，在肠道微生物的相对丰度上也表现出变化。
of abundances of microbes in the gut. So clearly an improvement at the brain level can have an effect on gut microbial composition. So I think we have to be really careful until we have these longitudinal interventional studies before we can say there's really a causality in one direction versus the other. Yeah, I wanted to talk about a recent study you interviewed about in nature microbiobiology, and that was about the link between gut bacteria and depression. So in that study, it was of 2,100 adults, and it found that people with depression had different groups of gut bacteria than people without depression.
肠道中微生物的相对丰度。因此，大脑层面的改善显然会对肠道微生物组成产生影响。所以我认为在进行这些纵向干预研究之前，我们必须非常谨慎，不能断言因果关系是单向的。是的，我想谈谈您在《自然-微生物学》中采访的一项近期研究，那是关于肠道细菌与抑郁症之间联系的研究。在那项研究中，涉及2100名成年人，发现患有抑郁症的人与没有抑郁症的人拥有不同的肠道细菌群。
So what are your thoughts about that study as well? Yeah, so it's, again, it's a nice study because it's a large study. It's also has the same limitation because it's a it's it's an association that that's been shown. There's a lot of variation that goes into a study like this. It's not like mice. If you study seven mice, seven term free mice and characterize abnormalities and metabolites and then relate this to behavior. Here you have a tremendous variability. in terms of genetics of the participating subjects,
那么您对那项研究有什么看法？是的，这又是一项很好的研究，因为它是一项大规模研究。它也有同样的局限性，因为它是一种被展示出来的关联。像这样的研究涉及很多变量。它不像小鼠。如果你研究七只无菌小鼠，描述代谢物的异常，然后将其与行为联系起来。在这里，你有巨大的变异性。在参与受试者的遗传学方面，
and the dietary habits, the medications that they're on, co-morbidities, that all could play a role here. And as I said, I mean, the gut-brain interaction is very sensitive to a lot of factors. Stress is one that we understand quite well. So it's limited by that. I mean, the association that they found with certain taxa and depression and quality of life is interesting. It does not, you know, prove causality in any way. And it's there's some similarities with, so there's a few of these depression studies in patients with major depressive disorder.
以及饮食习惯、他们服用的药物、合并症，所有这些都可能在这里发挥作用。正如我所说，脑肠互动对许多因素非常敏感。压力是我们了解得相当透彻的一个因素。所以它受到这种限制。我的意思是，他们发现的某些分类群与抑郁症和生活质量之间的关联很有趣。它并没有以任何方式证明因果关系。而且它与一些研究有一些相似之处，所以有几项针对重度抑郁症患者的抑郁症研究。
the findings that they have are not necessarily all consistent. There's some, this fecalibacterium shows up in several, in most of them actually. That's interesting. And I think it's definitely something that should be followed up in mouse studies. But I would look at this really with, still with a significant skepticism that it proves a causal relationship. Yes, I think I'm, you know, I'm really, as we've touched on a bunch of times, is that there's all this intriguing research, but before we get carried away, there needs to be more research and more work done in this space. Dr. Dickerson, I know you've been doing a lot of research with bipolar disorder. So can you talk about what you found in your work? Yes, our studies are different and present a different look and a different way of investigating this topic.
他们的发现并不一定都是一致的。有些，比如粪杆菌属在几项研究中出现，实际上在大多数研究中都出现了。这很有趣。我认为这绝对应该在小鼠研究中进行后续研究。但我仍然会以相当大的怀疑态度来看待它，认为它证明了因果关系。是的，我想，正如我们已经多次提到的，有所有这些有趣的发现，但在我们冲动行事之前，这个领域还需要更多的研究和工作。迪克森博士，我知道您一直在对双相情感障碍进行大量研究。那么您能谈谈您在工作中发现了什么吗？是的，我们的研究不同，呈现出不同的视角和调查该主题的方式。
The study that was most recently published last fall in the journal bipolar disorders was not of the microbiome directly, but was a clinical trial of probiotics. and probiotics have become very popular. They're widely used and advertised as having health benefits, which they may have. And probiotics are microorganisms that are introduced into the body for beneficial qualities. So they're compounds that contain actually live organisms that are thought to have a health benefit. So in all of this research, our ultimate goal obviously is to improve the symptoms and the lives of people, and in my case, patients who have psychiatric disorders. So what we did, again, based on our concept of the gut brain access, is we studied individuals who had been hospitalized for mania. And mania is a very acute psychiatric condition.
去年秋天发表在《双相情感障碍》杂志上的那项研究并非直接针对微生物组，而是益生菌的临床试验。益生菌已经变得非常流行。它们被广泛使用和宣传为具有健康益处，这可能是真的。益生菌是为获得有益品质而引入体内的微生物。所以它们是实际上含有活生物体的化合物，被认为具有健康益处。因此，在所有这些研究中，我们的最终目标显然是改善人们的症状和生活，在我的案例中，是患有精神疾病的患者。所以我们所做的是，再次基于我们对脑肠轴的概念，我们研究了因躁狂症住院的个体。躁狂症是一种非常急性的精神疾病。
Most people are probably familiar with the idea of it. Patients are very activated, unusually so, with rapid speech and flight of ideas and behavioral activation. And this syndrome, this condition can be very disruptive and can lead people in a psychiatric hospital where they can get treatment. So what we did, it was based on a previous study that we'd done that hadn't been a clinical trial, but just observing patients, is that we enrolled people who were hospitalized for mania when they were acutely, psychiatrically ill. And after they were discharged and they were more stable shortly after discharge, we enrolled them in a trial where they were randomized to receive either a probiotic compound. as a supplement or something that looked like the probiotic but was not the probiotic. So this is a standard design of a randomized controlled trial. And the idea that we had based on our previous work was that the probiotics would reduce
大多数人可能熟悉这个概念。患者非常活跃，异常活跃，言语急促，思维奔逸，行为激活。这种综合征、这种情况可能会造成很大的破坏，并可能导致人们进入精神病院接受治疗。所以我们所做的是，基于我们之前做过的一项研究（那不是临床试验，只是观察患者），我们招募了在急性精神疾病发作时因躁狂症住院的人。在他们出院且病情稍微稳定后，我们让他们参加了一项试验，随机分配接受益生菌化合物作为补充剂，或者看起来像益生菌但并非益生菌的物质。这是随机对照试验的标准设计。我们基于之前工作的想法是，益生菌会减少
intestinal inflammation and would help with their clinical course. The study that this was based on showed that a patient. admitted to the hospital for mania had elevations in inflammation and that the level of the inflammation was predictive of whether or not they were readmitted in a six-month follow-up period. So we thought that one way maybe to reduce inflammation and to help with this outcome would be to administer probiotics. So probiotics are pretty acceptable to patients. It wasn't that hard to recruit people for the,
肠道炎症，并有助于他们的临床病程。这项研究的基础显示，因躁狂症入院的患者炎症水平升高，且炎症水平可以预测他们在六个月随访期内是否会再次入院。所以我们认为，减少炎症并帮助改善这一结果的一种方法可能是服用益生菌。所以益生菌对患者来说是相当容易接受的。招募人员参加这项研究并不难，
the study because we know they're generally safe. So what we found was that in this trial that took a number of years to do, as you can imagine, to recruit the patients and to follow them for the six months, a period after hospital discharge, we found that those who were receiving the probiotics, that we only found out later when we broke the blind, so to speak, that the ones who were receiving the probiotics were significantly less likely to have a relapse, to have an exacerbation of psychobiotics. psychiatric symptoms in the study period, the six-month study period. So this was a proof of concept, as it will be considered, of the role of inflammation
因为我们知道它们通常是安全的。所以我们发现，在这项耗时数年的试验中（你可以想象，招募患者并跟踪他们出院后的六个月），我们发现那些接受益生菌的人——我们后来在揭盲时才发现——在研究期间，即六个月的研究期内，复发、精神症状加重的可能性显著降低。所以这被认为是关于炎症作用的概念验证，
and reducing inflammation, again, through the use of a probiotic compound to improve psychiatric outcomes. That's all very fascinating. And, of course, yeah, go on. If I can make a comment, I mean, this is definitely one of these examples of a very important study done in humans and sort of going towards a mechanism rather than just an association. And I think it sort of goes along with, you know, with our earliest study on this topic
并通过使用益生菌化合物来减少炎症，从而改善精神病学结果。这非常令人着迷。当然，请继续。如果我可以发表评论，我的意思是，这绝对是人类研究的一个非常重要的例子，并且倾向于机制而非仅仅是关联。我认为这与我们关于益生菌和大脑功能或活动的早期研究相一致，我们展示了健康年轻女性定期摄入益生菌改变了大脑中由情绪识别任务激活的整个网络的连接性。
of probiotics and brain function or activity, what we showed that the regular intake of a probiotic in healthy young women change the connectivity. of a whole network within the brain that was activated by an emotional recognition task. So we have not followed this up in a psychiatric population, but it certainly for us was a proof of concept that the signaling from the gut to the brain induced by a probiotic actually does happen as it happens in mice. So I think this mania study, but Dr. Dickus, is really, that's the kind of studies, I think, that we need to move this field forward.
我们还没有在精神病人群中进行后续研究，但这对于我们来说确实是一个概念验证，即由益生菌诱导的从肠道到大脑的信号传导确实发生了，就像在小鼠身上发生的那样。所以我认为这项躁狂症研究，迪克森博士，确实是我们推动该领域发展所需要的这类研究。
I think it's really an iterative process, understanding how some of these processes may work in animals, then human observational studies, testing them out in clinical trials, where, again, we aim to minimize any potential harm that patients would be exposed to, and then to circle back, again to other research realms. In this study, you might say, well, this is one study. It's one hospital. You know, you had a pretty good sample size, but again, you'd really need to replicate it to do the study again.
我认为这是一个迭代的过程，了解其中一些过程如何在动物身上发挥作用，然后进行人类观察研究，在临床试验中进行测试（再次强调，我们的目标是尽量减少患者可能面临的任何潜在伤害），然后再次回到其他研究领域。在这项研究中，你可能会说，好吧，这只是一项研究。这是一家医院。你知道，样本量还不错，但同样，你真的需要重复它，再次进行这项研究。
And in fact, this particular trial is being replicated at the University of Texas, where they're recruiting now for a similar study. and in the University of Texas study, unlike ours, they're actually getting measures of the gut microbiome. We had measures of the oral microbiome, which is kind of another chapter. But I think that we need to continue these studies with slightly different populations. We're also performing a trial now, also funded by the Stanley Medical Research Institute, in which we are performing a very similar study this time instead of starting with patients who are acutely manic, we are starting with patients who were admitted to the hospital
事实上，这项特定的试验正在德克萨斯大学进行重复，他们现在正在为一项类似的研究进行招募。在德克萨斯大学的研究中，与我们不同的是，他们实际上正在获取肠道微生物组的测量数据。我们有口腔微生物组的测量数据，那是另一个章节。但我认为我们需要用稍微不同的人群继续这些研究。我们现在也在进行一项试验，同样由斯坦利医学研究所资助，我们正在进行一项非常类似的研究，这次不是从急性躁狂患者开始，而是从因双相抑郁症入院的患者开始。
for bipolar depression. Because for people who have bipolar disorder, in fact, the depressive aspect of the illness is often the most disabling and does also result in hospital admissions. So we're doing a similar trial, but starting with people who are acutely depressed in the context of their bipolar disorder. So we're, you know, just recruiting now and enrolling people and they're taking their study minutes and we don't know which they're taking. And that's the kind of the excitement and the mystery of a clinical trial is really not knowing how it's going to turn out as the study is underway. And Dr. Mayor, I want to turn to you to talk about a book you wrote called The Mind Gut Connection.
因为对于患有双相情感障碍的人来说，事实上，疾病的抑郁方面往往是最致残的，也确实会导致住院。所以我们正在进行一项类似的试验，但从双相情感障碍背景下急性抑郁的人开始。所以我们现在正在招募和登记人员，他们正在服用研究药物，我们不知道他们服用的是哪一种。这就是临床试验的兴奋点和神秘之处，即在研究进行时真的不知道结果会如何。迈耶博士，我想请您谈谈您写的一本书，书名是《身心肠道联系》。
And in the book, you described the gut as having capabilities to surpass all other organs and even rival the brain. and that it stores 95% of all serotonin in our bodies, that hormone and neurotransmitor that regulates mood. Because our guts have direct connections to our brain through nerves, what happens when our brains and our guts are not in sync? Yeah, so this statement, it's not related that I'm a gastroenterologist, but it's partly related to the fact that I've studied these brain gut interactions for the better part of my career for the last 40 years. and what has become during that time what has become known is as it just said I mean it's it's the biggest endocrine organ in our body it's the biggest immune it's the biggest portion of our immune system it is the main storage site for for serotonin it has its own so-called enteric nervous system which you know has has been called the second brain even though it's really the first brain so
在书中，您描述肠道具有超越所有其他器官甚至可以与大脑相媲美的能力，并且它储存了我们体内95%的血清素，那种调节情绪的激素和神经递质。因为我们的肠道通过神经与大脑有直接联系，当我们的身心和肠道不同步时会发生什么？是的，所以这个陈述，并不是因为我是胃肠病学家，而是部分与我职业生涯的大部分时间（过去40年）都在研究这些脑肠互动有关。在这段时间里，人们已经知道，正如刚才所说，它是我们体内最大的内分泌器官，它是最大的免疫器官，是我们免疫系统中最大的一部分，它是血清素的主要储存场所，它有自己所谓的肠神经系统，你知道，它被称为“第二个大脑”，尽管它实际上是“第一个大脑”。
One of the questions is why is that? And well, the reason is during evolution, this gut brain of gut nervous system axis was really the first system of regulation. And then the microbes, the algae, came into this, what was originally just a floating digestive tube with a nerve net around it. And so this interaction between the microbeholder, some type of microbeholder, this very complex system in the gut with all these modules. And the brain is one of the most ancient biological systems in our body and has been maintained in virtually every life form from, you know, fruit flies to cockroaches to large animals to whales. It's almost ubiquitous. So you almost can say this is part of evolution and this close connection, which has really been neglected for a long time. I mean, it's really amazing to me.
其中一个问题是为什么会这样？嗯，原因是在进化过程中，这个肠脑或肠神经系统轴确实是第一个调节系统。然后微生物，藻类，进入了这个最初只是一个漂浮的消化管，周围有一张神经网的系统。因此，这种微生物持有者与肠道中这个非常复杂的系统（带有所有这些模块）之间的相互作用，是大脑中最古老的生物系统之一，并且在几乎每种生命形式中都得到了维持，从果蝇到蟑螂，再到大型动物和鲸鱼。它几乎无处不在。所以你几乎可以说这是进化的一部分，这种紧密的联系长期以来一直被忽视。我的意思是，这对我来说真的很神奇。
It took the microbes to stimulate the interests of people in the brain gut communication because, you know, people have been studying this for a long time. there's a lot of evidence that for this bidirectional communication in the brain regulating any of these other systems in the gut and the gut sending signals by multiple communication channels to the brain. So I would almost say this is like the main axis homeostatic, the main homestatic system within our bodies that has been around for the longest time and we're now just recognizing its importance in health and in disease. And I understand that stress can have a huge impact on a person's digestive health.
是微生物激发了人们对脑肠交流的兴趣，因为，你知道，人们研究这个问题已经很长时间了。有大量证据表明，这种双向交流中，大脑调节肠道中的任何这些系统，而肠道通过多种交流渠道向大脑发送信号。所以我几乎会说这是我们体内主要的稳态轴，是存在时间最长的主要稳态系统，我们现在才刚刚认识到它在健康和疾病中的重要性。我了解到压力会对一个人的消化健康产生巨大影响。
So how is our gut different when we're stressed and when we're relaxed? Well, you can almost say, you know, a turn that I used in my book, The gut is sort of the other side of the coin of an emotion. Any emotion, be it related to stress or not stress, will be reflected in changes in multiple gut functions, range from the simple thing, the contractions in different parts of the triadrack, the regional transit times, secretion of mucus, fluids, immune activation. When you stress, all of these functions are altered. When you stress acutely, it's an adaptive response. It goes up and then it settles back to its normal level. In chronic stress, it's different.
那么当我们有压力和放松时，我们的肠道有什么不同？嗯，你几乎可以说，我在书中用过的一个词，肠道是情绪的硬币的另一面。任何情绪，无论是与压力有关还是无关，都会反映在多种肠道功能的变化中，从简单的事情，即胃肠道不同部位的收缩、区域转运时间、粘液分泌、液体、免疫激活。当你感到压力时，所有这些功能都会改变。当你急性压力时，这是一种适应性反应。它上升，然后回落到正常水平。在慢性压力下，情况就不同了。
It becomes maladaptive. So many functions become not just maladaptive for our own health, but also to the microbes that live in it. And as I mentioned earlier, so no one of the NFAPE, has been particularly well studied on this. You know, one of the main stress mediators released by post-gangionic sympathetic nurse in the gut. It also goes up to concentration of noopenephrine in the gut lumen. There's certain microbes that actually metabolize the form of noopenephrine that's released inside the gut and make it more active.
它变得适应不良。所以许多功能不仅对我们自己的健康变得适应不良，而且对生活在其中的微生物也变得适应不良。正如我之前提到的，NFAPE（去甲肾上腺素）在这方面得到了特别好的研究。你知道，肠道中节后交感神经释放的主要压力介质之一。它也会上升到肠腔内去甲肾上腺素的浓度。有些微生物实际上会代谢在肠道内释放的去甲肾上腺素形式，并使其更具活性。
and it's been shown that this noopinephrine in the gut can modulate the behavior and the gene expression of a large number of microbes. First it was shown for pathogens. It makes pathogens more aggressive and more virulent. But it now also has shown for symbionts, so for the good guys in our gut, it changes their behavior. So you could almost say if you're chronically stressed, your gut is completely different in all its function and the alteration in the microbes will produce substances
研究表明，肠道中的这种去甲肾上腺素可以调节大量微生物的行为和基因表达。起初它被证明对病原体有效。它使病原体更具攻击性和毒力。但现在它也被证明对共生体有效，即对我们肠道中的“好人”有效，它会改变它们的行为。所以你几乎可以说，如果你长期处于压力之下，你的肠道在所有功能上都完全不同，微生物的改变会产生物质，
that get into your bloodstream and obviously some of them will reach the brain. Stress also increases the permeability of the gut. It's been referred to in the lay media is the leaky gut. So the leaky gut doesn't just happen in response to unhealthy food item like fat and sugar, but also really well studied in response to acute severe stress and chronic stress. With that mechanism, you get immune molecules into the circulation. So you can say, you know, when you're stressed, don't just worry about. but your heart and your blood pressure and the way it feels unpleasant,
进入你的血液，显然其中一些会到达大脑。压力也会增加肠道的通透性。在通俗媒体中，它被称为“肠漏症”。所以肠漏症不仅发生在对脂肪和糖等不健康食物的反应中，而且在对急性严重压力和慢性压力的反应中也得到了很好的研究。通过这种机制，免疫分子进入循环。所以你可以说，你知道，当你感到压力时，不要只担心你的心脏和血压以及它感觉不舒服的方式，
but you're doing something fundamental to one of the main regulatory systems in your body. Yeah, and it's been reported that hunter-gatherer tribes have more vibrant diverse gut microbiomes. How does that compare with the average Americans gut health? I mean, can they be compared? And what can we take away from that? Yeah, so there was a pivotal study. which was done a couple of years ago where they compared
你正在对你体内主要的调节系统之一做一些根本性的事情。是的，据报道，狩猎采集部落拥有更具活力、更多样化的肠道微生物组。这与普通美国人的肠道健康相比如何？我的意思是，它们可以比较吗？我们能从中得到什么启示？是的，所以有一项关键研究，是几年前做的，他们比较了
they took one of these hunter-gatherer tribes on the Orinoco River, the Yanomami Indians and looked at their relative abundances and richness, diversity of their gut microbiome and compared those to they did the study both in adults
他们选取了奥里诺科河上的一个狩猎采集部落——亚诺马米印第安人，观察了他们肠道微生物组的相对丰度和丰富度、多样性，并将其与他们所做的研究进行了比较，既有成年人
and in infants and they compared it to a population in North American cities, both again adults and infants, the remarkable thing was that there was a, I think it was about a 40% decrease in the richness and diversity of the gut microbiome in people living in North America. And that was even more intriguing that this was not only seen in the adults, but also in the infants.
也有婴儿，并将它们与北美城市的群体进行了比较，无论是成年人还是婴儿。令人瞩目的是，北美生活的人群中肠道微生物组的丰富度和多样性下降了约40%。更令人感兴趣的是，这不仅在成年人中观察到，在婴儿中也观察到了。
So it's not something that you lose, these bacteria as you grew up and have an unhealthy diet, you start out, we start out with that compromised diversity. So we've lost many of these organisms very early on. And during a period, it's obviously said that the first thousand days of life are so the most important for the maturing of the gut microbiome and its interactions with the immune system. So we start out very early on in life, and it's probably plays a role the transmission from the mother to the infant to the newborn, with a compromised microbial ecosystem, which has obviously, you know, major implications because people like Marty Blazer and this book, Missing Microb has shown this pretty dramatically. this decline in the diversity and relative abundance of certain organisms has been going on for the last
所以这不是你长大后饮食不健康而失去这些细菌的事情，我们从一开始就失去了这种多样性。我们在很早的时候就失去了许多这些生物。在这一时期，显然有人说生命的前一千天是肠道微生物组及其与免疫系统相互作用成熟的最重要时期。所以我们从生命早期就开始了，这可能在从母亲到婴儿、到新生儿的传播中起作用，伴随着一个受损的微生物生态系统，这显然有重大影响，因为像马蒂·布莱泽和这本《缺失的微生物》这样的书已经非常戏剧性地展示了这一点。这种某些生物多样性和相对丰度的下降在过去
hundred years or so and is continuing. So when you look at any other ecosystem, if you diminish the complexity and diversity of an ecosystem, it will lose its resilience and resistance against perturbations and diseases. So this is something I think we really have to worry about. Does that have anything to do with being in a world that's too clean? I think that's part of it. It does pretty many factors. It's obviously dietary.
一百年左右一直在发生，并且还在继续。所以当你观察任何其他生态系统时，如果你减少了生态系统的复杂性和多样性，它就会失去对扰动和疾病的弹性和抵抗力。所以这是我认为我们确实需要担心的事情。这与生活在一个太干净的世界里有关系吗？我认为这是其中的一部分。它确实有很多因素。显然是饮食。
I mean, these Yanomami Indians have obviously a very different diet. It is, even though they live in the middle of the jungles surrounded by all these wild animals, it's a predominantly plant-based diet with multiple different types of plants that they consume. And it's medications, antibiotic consumption in infants and in pregnant mothers is extremely high in the West. And there's other medications as well. So there's multiple factors. The hygiene hypothesis, so that's, you know, the excessive cleanliness and hygiene that we have in the Western world.
我的意思是，这些亚诺马米印第安人显然有非常不同的饮食。即使他们生活在丛林中间，被所有这些野生动物包围，这也是一种以植物为主的饮食，他们食用多种不同类型的植物。还有药物，西方婴儿和孕妇的抗生素消费量极高。还有其他药物。所以有多种因素。卫生假说，所以这就是，你知道，我们在西方世界拥有的过度清洁和卫生。
and it's pretty obvious if you travel to one of these places in the developing world, how dramatic the difference is, just in food preparation. And that's being implicated in a compromise training of the system early on in life during those first thousand days. So that our immune system does not see potential mild pathogens and does not really learn. to differentiate between self and non-self. And the increase in allergies and hypersensitivities and autoimmune diseases has been proposed that this hygiene hypothesis is really the explanation for it. Yeah.
如果你去发展中国家的这些地方旅行，你会发现差异是多么巨大，仅仅是在食物准备方面。这与生命早期（前一千天）系统受损的训练有关。所以我们的免疫系统看不到潜在的轻微病原体，也没有真正学会区分自我和非自我。过敏、超敏反应和自身免疫性疾病的增加，有人提出这种卫生假说确实是其解释。是的。
And I want to get both of your thoughts on companies that are offering to map your gut flora. So Dr. Dickerson, do you want to start off with that one? Right. I think that while that's an intriguing idea, it seems somewhat premature. I don't think the results would be easily interpretable. We don't really have standards by which to judge these results. It seems like, quite honestly, it might be a little bit of a waste of money. Maybe benign, unless people were told something about their health that was alarming or actionable in a way that would be, would be. damaging to them. But I think, I think at this point it's really premature. Although, you know, one can see that it would be kind of intriguing to do it, you know, given that we're all kind of learning more about this microbiome and kind of intrigued and have no way to measure it ourselves. You know, it's not like we can look inside our gut and figuring it out. So I think it's intriguing, but premature at this point. Yeah. My common on this is, and I have to disclose that I am
我想听听你们两位对那些提供肠道菌群测绘服务的公司的看法。迪克森博士，你想先谈谈吗？好的。我认为虽然这是一个引人入胜的想法，但似乎有些操之过急。我不认为这些结果能轻易解读。我们并没有真正衡量这些结果的标准。老实说，这似乎有点浪费钱。除非人们被告知了一些关于他们健康状况的、令人担忧或需要采取行动的信息，否则这可能无害，但如果这些信息对他们有害，那就另当别论了。但我认为，在这一点上，这确实为时过早。虽然你知道，考虑到我们都在更多地了解这种微生物群，并且对此感到好奇，但我们自己又无法测量它，所以你会觉得这样做很有趣。你知道，我们不可能直接观察自己的肠道并弄清楚它。所以我认为这很有趣，但目前还为时过早。是的，我对此的评论是，我必须披露我
on the advisory boards of several of such companies, the leading companies in this area. And I still have a certain degree of skepticism as well as enthusiasm for something like that becoming really a routine test that instead of getting a blood test, where you look at 10 substances in your blood, 10 measures, and then make predictions about your health.
是几家此类公司的顾问委员会成员，也是该领域领先的公司。对于这种测试成为一种常规检查，我仍然持有一定的怀疑态度，同时也抱有热情。这种测试取代了验血，验血时你查看血液中的10种物质、10项指标，然后对你的健康做出预测。
I think this has the potential to go much further than that. And clearly, you know, in combination with genetic testing. So we're definitely moving into a future with these technologies that are now available in the supercomputers that can make sense out of the data will pretty fundamentally change. Medicine, diagnostics, health assessment, risk assessment. But we're still in the middle. of this process. You know, there's one company, actually not involved with it, that postulates in their
我认为这有潜力走得更远。显然，你知道，这与基因检测相结合。所以我们肯定正在迈向一个未来，这些技术现在在超级计算机中可用，能够解读这些数据，并将从根本上改变医学、诊断、健康评估和风险评估。但我们仍处于这个过程的中间。你知道，有一家公司，实际上我没有参与其中，他们在他们的
advertising that you can, if you have type 2 diabetes, metabolic syndrome, that you can tailor your specific diet that's good for you and that does not worsen the syndrome, that you can basis on an assessment of the gut microbiome. That, you know, that needs, it's based on a lot of high quality research papers in both animal and humans. But it needs to be determined or needs to be seen in the next few years, which one of these approaches turns out to be good enough. So they're going to be adopted by insurance companies.
广告中假设，如果你患有2型糖尿病、代谢综合征，你可以定制适合你的特定饮食，且不会加重综合征，你可以基于对肠道微生物群的评估来做到这一点。你知道，这需要，它是基于大量高质量的动物和人类研究论文。但需要在未来几年内确定或观察，这些方法中哪一种足够好。这样它们才会被保险公司采用。
and so that if you ask me what the likelihood is that this is going to happen, it's going to happen. I think I would say it's probably close to 70% as all right now. The way it says it's, but we're not quite there yet. Yeah, I think it's an example where the technology at this point is ahead of our complete understanding and the interpretability of the data. But I think the technology is there, and once there's more knowledge, potentially these methods, would be informative. But I think now it would, you know, if one did it more out of curiosity and not putting much faith, so to speak, in the results, I think it would be interesting, but not really as a diagnostic or therapeutic tool.
所以如果你问我这发生的可能性有多大，它会发生的。我想我会说现在可能接近70%。虽然它说是这样，但我们还没有完全达到那个阶段。是的，我认为这是一个例子，技术在这一点上领先于我们对数据的完全理解和可解释性。但我认为技术已经存在，一旦有了更多的知识，这些方法可能会提供信息。但我认为现在，你知道，如果一个人更多是出于好奇而不是对结果寄予厚望，我认为这会很有趣，但并不能真正作为一种诊断或治疗工具。
And can people do anything to improve their gut health? Well, that's always an interesting question. I mean, we know from studies, some of which have mentioned in this podcast that diabetes is associated with aspects of the microbiome and obesity. We haven't mentioned antibiotics yet, actually. Antibiotics have a major effect on the microbiome that I can tell you a study we've done about antibiotics and patients with mania. But based on what we know so far, I think we can assume that if patients have a healthy weight, and if they have diabetes, if their diabetes is in control, and if they avoid unnecessary antibiotics, that that's likely to improve their microbiome.
人们能做些什么来改善他们的肠道健康吗？嗯，这总是一个有趣的问题。我的意思是，我们从研究中知道，其中一些研究在这个播客中提到过，糖尿病与微生物群和肥胖的某些方面有关。实际上，我们还没有提到抗生素。抗生素对微生物群有重大影响，我可以告诉你我们做过的一项关于抗生素和躁狂症患者的研究。但基于我们目前所知，我认为我们可以假设，如果患者体重健康，如果他们患有糖尿病且糖尿病得到控制，并且如果他们避免不必要的抗生素使用，那么这很可能会改善他们的微生物群。
Again, we don't know quite in what direction the microbiome affects these conditions and vice versa, but we do know that there are some ways that people can, in general, improve their gut health. Yeah, I would say also this question about gut health, so people always want to know this, what can I do for my gut microbial health and my gut health? So we always assume that the two of them are interrelated. But, you know, in terms of probably the best thing that you can do is you stay away from unnecessary intake of medications and particularly antibiotics. And I do want to emphasize unnecessary because obviously antibiotics are life-saving in any conditions.
同样，我们并不完全清楚微生物群在多大程度上影响这些疾病，反之亦然，但我们确实知道人们通常可以通过一些方法改善肠道健康。是的，我也会说关于肠道健康的问题，人们总是想知道这一点，我能为我的肠道微生物健康和肠道健康做些什么？所以我们总是假设这两者是相互关联的。但是，你知道，就你可能能做的最好的事情而言，就是远离不必要的药物摄入，特别是抗生素。我确实想强调“不必要”，因为显然抗生素在任何情况下都是救命的。
And to be on a healthy diet, I think we know from even long before the microbiome science coming on the horizon that a largely plant-based diet has the greatest benefit on cardiovascular brain function, metabolic diseases. So part of that beneficial effect of the diet, for example, is mediated by the microbes. but not all of it. We know that so many effects on metabolic health are not mediated through the microbial metabolites that are generated from a plant-based diet. What the ratio is between a direct effect, for example, of health-promoting food on our gut,
并且保持健康的饮食，我认为即使在微生物群科学出现之前很久，我们就知道以植物为主的饮食对心血管、大脑功能、代谢疾病有最大的益处。所以饮食的这种有益效果的一部分，例如，是由微生物介导的，但并非全部。我们知道，对代谢健康的许多影响并不是通过植物性饮食产生的微生物代谢物来介导的。健康促进食物对我们肠道的直接影响，例如，
like all the things that are being absorbed in a small intestine, and not metabolized by microbes, as opposed to what role the microbial-generated products, by-products from our diet is, I think that needs to be determined, but it's two ways, I think, that you can affect God-Tales, diet directly and diet through the intermediary of microbes. Yeah, what about foods like yogurt, you know, kimchi, kombucha, sourcrow? they get a lot of tension for being good for us because they're fermented foods. Do those have any impact on your gut health, the Jep's system?
像所有在小肠中被吸收且未被微生物代谢的东西，与微生物产生的饮食副产品所起的作用相比，我认为这需要确定，但我认为有两种方式可以影响肠道健康：直接饮食和通过微生物中介的饮食。是的，像酸奶、泡菜、康普茶、酸菜这样的食物呢？它们因为是发酵食品而受到很多关注，认为对我们有好处。这些对你的肠道健康有任何影响吗，杰普系统？
Well, one thing to say at the outset is the many products that are promoted and sold, for many of them we really don't know if they contain the active organisms that they claim or the concentration of the organisms. And that is a major issue because most of these products are not really regulated by the FDA. so it's hard to know. I would say that if these organisms are present and present in a sufficient quantity, that they may be beneficial.
嗯，首先要说的一件事是，许多被推广和销售的产品，对于其中许多产品，我们真的不知道它们是否含有它们声称的活性生物，或者生物的浓度是多少。这是一个主要问题，因为这些产品中的大多数并没有真正受到FDA的监管。所以很难知道。我会说，如果这些生物存在并且数量充足，它们可能是有益的。
Yeah, I would say I would agree with this. I think the, I would probably say that 90% of the commercial available products, supplements, and, you know, various pro and prebiotics are not based, or not evidence-based, for example, confirmed by the gold standard, a randomized clinical controlled trial.
是的，我会同意这一点。我认为，我可能会说90%的商业可用产品、补充剂以及各种益生菌和益生元，都不是基于证据的，例如，没有经过黄金标准——随机临床对照试验的证实。
So you would never be allowed to sell a medication with this limited amount of evidence. And I'm sure that a big portion of the benefits that people derive from taking different types of probiotics and prebiotics, you could consider a placebo. response. So it's nothing bad. It's actually placebo response is always good.
所以你永远不会被允许销售证据如此有限的药物。我相信人们从服用不同类型的益生菌和益生元中获得的好处，很大一部分可以被认为是安慰剂反应。所以这没什么坏处。实际上，安慰剂反应总是好的。
But the actual health benefit I mean my recommendation to patients is start out with naturally fermented products as you said the kimchi and the yogurt and the
但实际的健康益处，我的意思是，我对患者的建议是从天然发酵产品开始，正如你所说的泡菜和酸奶，以及
rather than taking pills with probiotics and in just your prebiotics with a high variety of plant-based foods, which are all full of prebiotics, instead of taking, again, taking pills with prebiotics, with a single prebiotic, if those things are not available, for some reason or another, if you're in the North Pole, and you may benefit from taking, you know, some of these substances in pill form. And Dr. Dickerson, in that monitor piece, you talked about psychobiotics. Can you explain what those are?
而不是服用益生菌药丸，并且摄入富含益生元的各种植物性食物，这些食物都充满了益生元，而不是再次服用含有单一益生元的药丸。如果这些东西由于某种原因无法获得，如果你在北极，你可能会从服用这些物质的药丸形式中受益。迪克森博士，在那篇《监测》文章中，你谈到了精神益生菌。你能解释一下那是什么吗？
Right. Psychobiotics are organisms that when ingested in adequate amounts, live organisms when ingested in adequate amounts, produce mental health benefits. So again, we haven't established absolutely that the ingestion of live organisms does produce mental health benefits, but in, theory, something like a probiotic compound, if it were to be a determined and established in evidence-based trials, that it was helpful. That would be an example of a psychobiotic. Kind of an interesting combination of a term here. And so I want to get both of your takes on this. So what is needed to continue research in this field?
好的。精神益生菌是当以足够量摄入时，活的生物体当以足够量摄入时，能产生心理健康益处的生物体。所以同样，我们还没有绝对确定摄入活的生物体确实能产生心理健康益处，但在理论上，像益生菌化合物这样的东西，如果它被确定并在循证试验中证实是有帮助的。那将是精神益生菌的一个例子。这里的一个术语组合很有趣。所以我想听听你们两位的看法。那么，在这个领域继续研究需要什么？
Is it more funding, more grants? What do you both think? I'll start with you, Dr. Dickerson. Well, certainly we can always use more funding. And a new area of research, like the one we're discussing, it falls among and between our usual research silos. So here we have a gastroenterologist participating in this podcast. I'm a psychologist. It falls, to some extent, in complementary and alternative medicine because these are not established medications.
是更多的资金，更多的拨款吗？你们两位怎么看？我先从你开始，迪克森博士。嗯，当然我们总是需要更多的资金。在一个新的研究领域，就像我们正在讨论的这个，它介于我们通常的研究孤岛之间。所以在这里，我们有一位胃肠病学家参加这个播客。我是一位心理学家。它在某种程度上属于补充和替代医学，因为这些不是已确立的药物。
per se. So there's always the question of funding of who is really taking the lead in this area. And as often happens, there are a number of different traditional research silos which are moving ahead. So again, definitely grant funding. I also think there are regulatory issues. It hasn't been absolutely and fully established. What is the role of the FDA? How much oversight, They need and do have. These are new kinds of compounds to be tested that don't fall in the categories of traditional medications. Prebiotics were mentioned a while ago. Those are not live microorganisms, but do serve to promote the growth of healthy organisms in the GI tracts.
本身。所以总是存在资金问题，即谁在这一领域真正处于领先地位。正如经常发生的那样，有许多不同的传统研究孤岛正在向前推进。所以同样，绝对需要拨款。我也认为存在监管问题。还没有绝对和完全确定FDA的角色是什么。他们需要并确实拥有多少监督权。这些是需要测试的新型化合物，不属于传统药物的类别。刚才提到了益生元。那些不是活的微生物，但确实有助于促进胃肠道中健康生物的生长。
So the regulation of prebiotics, the regulation of probiotics. these regulatory issues for human subject trials, I think also need to be better clarified. And there are some barriers here into performing this research with clinical patients. What do you think, Dr. Amir? Yeah, I mean, I would agree with this. I think, you know, just make one comment on the kind of research that's needed. I think that's very important. And this is already happening to a certain degree.
所以益生元的监管，益生菌的监管。这些针对人类受试者试验的监管问题，我认为也需要更好地澄清。在对临床患者进行这项研究方面存在一些障碍。你认为呢，迈耶博士？是的，我的意思是，我会同意这一点。我认为，你知道，只对所需的研究类型发表一点评论。我认为这非常重要。而且这在某种程度上已经在发生了。
So for the human studies, and I personally believe that it's the best approach to do something in humans first to really characterize that it plays a role and then go back to the animal model and look at the mechanism. I think that's somehow more rewarding than starting with relatively artificial animal models and then only a very small fraction are translatable into human populations. A good example, intractable seizures. We, for example, have known that a ketogenic diet is beneficial, is therapeutic. And then a study came from an investigator at UCLA, Elaine Scha, that showed that this ketogenic diet changes the microbes to produce metabolites that are responsible for a change in the seizure threshold. So this is like this reverse translation. I think that's one. The other one in human studies, we need large numbers because you have a lot of variables now that you can measure from the microbial abundance, the metabolites, genetics of the host, and then various other parameters, clinical parameters.
所以对于人类研究，我个人认为首先在人类身上做一些事情来真正表征它所起的作用，然后再回到动物模型并研究机制，这是最好的方法。我认为这比从相对人工的动物模型开始，然后只有很小一部分可以转化为人类群体要更有价值。一个很好的例子是难治性癫痫。例如，我们已经知道生酮饮食是有益的、是治疗性的。然后加州大学洛杉矶分校的一位研究员伊莱恩·夏（Elaine Hsiao）进行了一项研究，表明这种生酮饮食改变了微生物，从而产生负责改变癫痫阈值的代谢物。所以这就像这种反向转化。我认为这是一个。另一个在人类研究中，我们需要大量的数字，因为你现在可以测量很多变量，从微生物丰度、代谢物、宿主遗传学，以及各种其他参数、临床参数。
You need very large data sets to do that. And so it will require consortia, most likely in. international consortia that can generate 10,000 subjects, data from 10 subjects. And that's probably one of these two approaches that you go to the reverse translation and you go to very large data sets and then use artificial intelligence to extract patterns and identify predictors. to me that's really the most promising approach. And the NIH, for example, has taken that approach.
你需要非常大的数据集来做到这一点。因此，它将需要联盟，很可能是国际联盟，能够生成1万名受试者的数据。这可能是这两种方法之一，即你进行反向转化，然后转向非常大的数据集，然后使用人工智能来提取模式并识别预测因子。对我来说，这确实是最有希望的方法。例如，美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）就采取了这种方法。
So we're involved in a study, in a cooperative study on cognitive decline. What this is exactly being done with a consortium of U.S. and European investigators collecting data on patients. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Dickerson and Dr. Mayor. This has been a really wonderful conversation. Thank you. It's a pleasure to be on the show. Thank you very much.
所以我们参与了一项关于认知能力下降的合作研究。这正是通过一个由美国和欧洲研究人员组成的联盟来完成的，他们正在收集患者的数据。非常感谢你们加入我们，迪克森博士和迈耶博士。这是一次非常精彩的谈话。谢谢。很高兴能参加这个节目。非常感谢。
And if you'd like to read the Monitor story on the Mindgut connection, visit APA's website at APA.org slash monitor. If you've been a long-time listener or are new to our podcast, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. And if you have time, write a review, we'd really appreciate it. Also, we'd like to hear from you directly. So if you have any questions, comments, or ideas to share, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org.
如果你想阅读《监测》关于身心联系的故事，请访问美国心理学会（APA）的网站 APA.org/monitor。如果你是我们的长期听众，或者刚开始收听我们的播客，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。如果你有时间，写一篇评论，我们将不胜感激。此外，我们想直接听取你的意见。所以如果你有任何问题、评论或想法要分享，请发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。
That's K-L-U-N-A-A-R-A-A-A-P-E-A-A-R. speaking of psychology is part of the APA podcast network which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology you can find all our podcasts on iTunes stitcher or wherever you get your podcast you can also visit our website speaking of psychology.org to listen to more episodes i'm kately luna with the american psychological association There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 K-L-U-N-A-A-R-A-A-A-P-E-A-A-R。《谈论心理学》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他很棒的播客，如《APA期刊对话》关于新的心理学研究，以及《进度记录》关于心理学实践。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是凯特琳·卢纳，来自美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。